distant Thompson has been omnipresent  five blocks 23 points ten rebounds a  great goon don't you get the Cavaliers a  six-point lead let the Bulls won another  timeout whoa  Kevin Love started a sequence with a  mid-range jumper over Thaddeus Young the  Cavaliers have taken this six-point lead  great touch off the window and then at  the other end Carter tried to bustle it  in and Tristan Thompson's incredible  night continues he lets Carter know  about it and then Collins xyn gets the  feed and does the rest he kept he caught  Lavine sleeping that time the beam  turned the bar watch Kevin i mean ii did  a great job of getting to the basket and  throwing the hammer down